- I'm here in one of the most
special places on the planet
because there's a natural phenomenon
that occurs here and nowhere else.
I'm Phil Torres, Atlas Obscura tour guide,
researcher, and science communicator.
And today, I'm leading a group through
the butterfly sanctuaries
in Michoacán, Mexico.
This is where tens of millions
of monarch butterflies
migrate every year to spend the winter.
And the history behind
the scientific discoveries
and the significance to the local culture
are just as fascinating as
the butterflies themselves.
- The way the story of the
discovery of these places
gets told is that it was in the mid-1970s
when people finally figured out where
the monarch butterflies went every winter.
That story is
not untrue, but it ignores
the part where all the people
who lived in these places were aware
that monarch butterflies showed
up every year in the winter.
- This is incredible.
The trees are just orange,
they're like carpeting.
Look back there, it's amazing!
Wow!
That's me, Joe Hanson, biologist,
science communicator, and YouTuber.
I've been fascinated by the story of
the monarch butterfly and
their epic journey for years.
So I jumped at the
opportunity to go explore
their overwintering home
in Mexico along with
Atlas Obscura to learn more about
this epic bit of nature,
and its discovery.
Now I'm gonna talk more
about how they accomplish
this epic feat over on my
channel, It's Okay To Be Smart.
In the early 20th century,
scientists in North America
and Canada were wondering:
Where do the butterflies go
when they flew south for the winter?
In 1937, a Canadian zoologist
named Fred Urquhart,
along with his wife, Norah, began a quest
to answer that question.
In the 1940s, the Urquharts
had devised an ingenious
way to tag monarch butterflies,
and thousands of volunteers
across North America
tagged these butterflies and
reported their sightings.
But every year, the
migration trail vanished
at the Texas-Mexico border.
In 1973, Fred Urquhart
put an ad in a Mexico City
newspaper looking for research assistants,
and two people answered:
an American named Ken
Brugger and his girlfriend
and later wife, a young Mexican
woman named Catalina Aguado.
For the next two years,
Catalina and Ken traveled
the Mexican countryside,
interviewing the locals
and counting the
butterflies along the road.
They immediately sent word
back to the Urquharts,
and the following year, in
1976, Fred Urquhart himself
made the walk up the
mountain to "discover"
the monarch overwintering forest.
The credit for the
discovery of the monarch
overwintering habitat traditionally goes
to the Urquharts, and that makes sense.
They did so much work
to track and to study
this migration across North America.
But Catalina is only
mentioned in one line of
the story, "a bright and
delightful Mexican, 'Cathy,'"
and today, as we know,
uncredited on the cover,
the young woman dressed in butterflies.
But this place was, and is,
special to more than just scientists.
- So each of the sanctuaries
is managed by something
called an "ejido," which
is a uniquely Mexican form
of land tenure that dates back
to the Mexican Revolution.
The idea is that the government grants
to these communities the
right to manage their lands,
and the right to create economic
opportunities off of their lands.
Each community that
manages these sanctuaries
gets the revenue from the ticket sales,
from renting the horses that you take
to get up onto the mountain,
from selling you food,
and selling you gifts at the gift shop.
And then as a community, each
of the members of the ejido
collectively determine
how to spend that money
for the benefit of the community.
It's one of the most successful models for
community-based conservation
that we have in the world.
The local guides that you interact with,
the ones that take you
up onto the mountain,
this is their home,
this is their backyard.
This is where their families have lived,
sometimes for generations,
and so you're not just
helping to protect this
charismatic species,
but you're also giving these communities
an incentive to continue
protecting their home.
You're giving them a reason
to continue acting as stewards
over this place.